this is your opening where's my two
minutes of motivational marvel theming
what's the rush guys
calling the person you want to protect
you an idiot premature decapitation
gold molap
[Music]
whoever you are
we can make a deal negotiating with a
hit monkey hit monkey attended the
captain america civil war school of
labeling cities business or pleasure
oh that's a great question and when you
love what you do it's such a hard one to
answer really not ted lasso is incorrect
no one likes working more than pleasure
i love being an [ __ ] complaining
about television shows but if you told
me i could still get paid the same but
i'd spend my time lying poolside looking
at i mean reading the articles in adult
magazines i do it that is where the cool
kids get their porn right magazines hey
are you gonna be out here when i get
back because i gotta be honest with you
i'm really enjoying the conversation
we're having i'm always happy to watch
and or listen to the sedacus but damn
the only way this character could be any
more of an archer rip-off is if he ends
up with mommy issues and aversion to
attracting ants or starts putting his
pistol where it doesn't belong phrasing
just the back and forth is incredible so
giving your driver for not having a
conversation with you that's not his job
his job is to drive from point a to
point b and then get home to his wife
and kids to catch up on the last three
seasons of top chef we're not judging
neither should you let him be mr schuler
no ma'am wait are we using real names or
fake names gonna go out on a limb and
say if bryce is this good at his job
this is info he should have already had
before landing in tokyo i'm not here to
judge anyone's personal aesthetic but
isn't a middle-aged man wearing a
backpack clearly designed for children a
somewhat conspicuous item of apparel for
an assassin you know you really should
get that checked out it's fine
okay yeah i mean it's just i have a big
day tomorrow and i hate working sick how
is getting her cough checked later gonna
help him not get sick tomorrow if
whatever she has is contagious i'm sorry
to say you've probably already got him a
man this is why real heroes wear a mask
also bryce is a dick to the sick are the
hotel employees carrying bryce's guns
how has bryce not been caught yet who
would hire him if he's this
lackadaisical about his work maybe we
can watch some tv if you want you know i
can order a porno or love actually
inviting the hotel staff that you've
just met to watch an inappropriate film
that pretends to have a plot or even a
porno
dance like nobody's watching bryce
objects to working with a cold but a
furious hangover is apparently what
keeps him at optimum efficiency remind
me again why i made you his speech
writer because i'm awesome vanity i
think i hate working political rallies i
think i have a very different definition
of working than random security details
sitting at the bar nursing a beer while
complaining gentlemen
good morning assuming the gender of your
sniper rifles can't i remember my
password with his ass
ass man
yes this is a dumb password for an
assassin but the fact that bryce even
entertained ass man as a possibility is
even dumber also when was the last time
you were allowed to create a password
without a special character or at least
one number can't even log into twitter
without sending off a stool sample in a
pint of blood wait is that not normal
no 15. thanks for the input but i'll be
leaning towards trusting the guy that
isn't drinking beer while on protection
duty
well that's a lot of stairs probably why
oswald only went to the sixth floor
grassy knoll deniers
young police officer goes in without
backup and gets himself killed causing
veteran cop to be sad and possibly use
this moment to devote his life to carry
out a vendetta cliche and i haven't seen
the rest of the series so if i'm wrong
then we'll go with tv sins narrator 100
misreads a scene in the pilot episode of
a series and looks dumb after everyone
has watched the remaining episodes and
will let him know in the comments cliche
buying multiple beers for yourself at
once the second beer is going to be
mildly chilled at best and room
temperature at worst by the time he gets
it alcohol dependency or no there's
really no excuse for lukewarm beer also
mopey assassin mobily being mopey mopes
on for all the mope time you mean this
money
i believe i'm supposed to collect this
back double crossers
bryce survives this nope that doesn't
quite cut it after a point-blank
explosion of this magnitude let's try
bryce should be an unrecognizable
sudeikis voice pulpy smear on the runway
after that explosion survives this
character doesn't realize they've been
shot until after they've noticed their
bleeding cliche what happens now is that
bryce passes out in the snow from a gsw
and is dragged away to a natural hot tub
by a group of macaques where they then
proceed to nurse him back to health with
pre-masticated flowers and head rubs and
he is totally [ __ ] fine with this and
it works you know i'm pretty sure you
guys are outside of my provider's
network wasting bad jokes on monkeys why
is erection if bryce is healed up why
doesn't he just leave and do some real
training instead of [ __ ] around with
these winter snoulders who can't
possibly hold up as a suitable
replacement for living and moving
adversaries
random baby monkey would be the cutest
at tv sins yes he would hey man i'm
sorry about that i was just screwing
around does bryce think these monkeys
understand everything he's saying
because i think bryce thinks these
monkeys understand everything he's
saying bro
did you honestly think you could get
away with this bro you've obviously been
hired and most likely paid a fair amount
of money to assassinate this individual
and you open with bro is a degree of
professionalism too much to ask for
people i know what's the point but this
still feels like a recrementitious
amount of megacaside oh that was baller
dude encouraging murder look i don't
want to make it weird but you and me
are connected but why this is exactly
what hong kong snowy predicted would
happen so why does he suddenly seem to
give a sh that ted assassin is dying he
just lost his entire family because of
bryce he should be finishing the job or
at least flinging some poop in his
general direction you're gonna find the
[ __ ] who did this just you you were
the [ __ ] that did this to us ah
the last samurai here has somehow
learned how to be an assassin after
watching just one session of bryce
fighting and i repeat stationary snow
people is he waiting for a train with a
clearly visible assault rifle on his
back that's ridiculous oh yeah and he's
a monkey waiting for a train suppose
that's weird too
this little monkey could be the [ __ ]
damn dirty eight responsible for the
fall of the human race
i promised myself i was never going to
watch fresh prince again when they
swapped out amp vivs but truth be told
as long as they let carlton do his thing
i was always going to take him in just
sit right there
you're alive i saved you
do i get any thanks no all you can do is
clam up
lana
lana
lana
what danger zone ah it feels like
nobody's watching i'm wetting my pants
why can't i remember my password with
his ass
ass man i'm i'm not the ass man i think
there's been a mistake hey bryce
you want to go to japan come on to the
coast we get together have a few lives
[Applause]
that equins urge apart did you just
refer to me as white devil
remember
the force will be with you always